[Music]
the first and most necessary division in
philosophy is that which has to do with
the application of the principles as for
example do not lie
the second deals with the demonstrations
as for example how comes it that we
ought not to lie
the third confirms and discriminates
between these processes as for example
how does it come that this is a proof
for what is a proof what is logical
consequence what contradiction what
truth what falsehood
therefore the third division is
necessary because of the second and the
second because of the first while the
most necessary of all and the one in
which we ought to rest is the first
but we do the opposite for we spend our
time in the third division and all our
zeal is devoted to it while we utterly
neglect the first
wherefore we lie indeed but are ready
with the arguments which prove that one
ought not to lie
here in chapter 52 epictetus is
referencing a sort of technical
distinction that gets made in stoic
philosophy and it's an important one
it's a methodological distinction you
don't necessarily have to know a lot
about stoic philosophy in order to
appreciate this distinction and why he's
saying that one part is more important
whereas
too much attention is paid to another
part so he talks about these as
divisions the greek for that is topos
and so think of these as three different
chapters you might want to say right or
three different parts of the discipline
where ethics and logic are coming
together
so he says the first and most necessary
part of philosophy is that which has to
do with the application of the
principles the word application there is
translating crisis or or use it's not
just merely applying but it's applying
in a certain way it's how we use the
principles or the
theorem
would be would be the the nominative for
it that we we have come to know and so
he has the example and we're going to
come back to this this important example
of for you know do not lie right as a
imperative so
how do we actually apply that well or
how do we use it we try not to lie if
we're lying we catch ourselves and say
wait a second as a stoic i've got to
avoid this or even as a decent person i
need to avoid
lying right so that's one part and it
gives us a set of rules or injunctions
it's not all merely imperatives but um
that's a good part of it right and this
is practical reasoning this is sort of
the culmination of it and then we have
to apply that to particular
circumstances does this count as lying
in these circumstances is not saying
anything when i'm asked a question lying
what if i say something but i leave some
parts out those are all within this
first division
the second party says deals with
demonstrations or if you like proofs or
or arguments the greek for that is
apodexus
and this is showing somebody something
it doesn't necessarily have to mean
demonstrative
you know deductive reasoning it could be
by way of giving examples which would be
inductive but in any case what it does
is it provides a justification or if
somebody's asking not so much for a
justification but an explanation why is
this the way it is and so he says
for example how comes it that we ought
not to lie what is the cause why why is
it important
that we don't lie and here it might be
the whole range of you know considering
priorities and weighing goods against
each other and thinking about well what
does a lie do to me and so that's that's
all very important as well and then he
said the third part
confirms and discriminates between
these processes and here we get more
abstract we're getting further away from
the phenomenon itself the the key matter
that we're talking about so what's an
example of that uh it asks well how does
it come that this is a proof
for what is a proof
what is logical consequence what
contradiction what truth what falsehood
and this is now within the realm of what
the stoics called logic right so
epictetus is trying to make the point
that when it comes to ethics
what's really important is the first and
the second but the first is the most
important because that's where the
proverbial rubber hits the road right
your tires actually have to get some
traction on on something that's where we
run into real cases that's where we
either win or lose by making the right
choices or making the wrong choices or
you know if we make the wrong choices do
we catch ourselves do we correct
ourselves do we admit our faults move on
or do we try to deny it and so what does
he tell us further about this he says
the third division
is
necessary but why is it necessary it's
necessary because of the second division
we want to try to prove something right
we want to prove that we shouldn't lie
or that lying is universally wrong or
pick however else you want to come up
with this you know thinking about why it
affects
the kind of person that we are
the third
is about
more abstract logical principles and it
does have a lot of implications for
practical reasoning but it's not itself
practical reasoning is it it's it's
theoretical reasoning and so the third
part is necessary on account of the
second part so that when we go about
providing arguments we don't make bad
arguments or we're not taken in by other
people making bad arguments there's a
lot there's a lot of ways of stringing
things together that turn out to be
insupportable arguments so studying
logic really can be quite useful as a
matter of fact it's it's something that
the stoics thought was necessary and
epictetus in his own classes not in the
discourses that we have or in the end
caridian but we know that he taught
logic in his stoic school
so this the the third is important
because of the second or it's necessary
because of that
and he says the second is necessary
because of the first
right
why why is it laid out that way well
because that's where things actually
happen
in applying using the principles that
are coming to us in this first
so it's very important to get this first
part
right
because it feeds back into the second
and feeds back into the third likewise
it's important to get the third right
because that feeds into the second and
it's important to get the second right
because that feeds into the first we can
we can inherit a lot of
cultural prohibitions
and uh you know imperatives that turn
out to be baseless when we examine them
and we ask for proof and so perhaps uh
you know the second is kind of a a
gatekeeper or kind of a
control on on the first right and
likewise the third so they all have an
important role but when we're thinking
about our lives and about where we
actually do things that are going to
count
it's with respect to the first
so where's where's the problem then
well he says
the first is the most necessary of all
and the one in which we ought to rest
that's where we ought to be placing most
of our focus
that's where we ought to be
spending our time to see whether we're
getting it actually right or not that's
the sort of thing where if you're like
keeping a notebook and writing things
down about how you did during the day
and measuring whether you're making
progress or not it's going to be in line
with this first uh part of stoic
philosophy right
but what do we do instead
and this applies not just to academic
philosophers this also applies to people
who want to be you might say dilettantes
when it comes to stoic philosophy
amateurs people who are just kind of you
know puttering around with it he says
we spend our time we do the opposite we
spend our time in the third division and
all our zeal all of our attention all of
our work
ends up getting
spent on that
we utterly neglect the first
this is a major problem remember this
the third is important because of the
second the second is important because
of the first and they all sort of you
know feed into each other reinforce each
other if all we're doing is
focusing on these these important
questions like the ones that he just
said what is proof what is logical
consequence what is contradiction what
is truth what is falsehood these are
important but if that's all we're
focusing on
and we neglect the other parts
we're going to manage things badly when
it comes to our practical lives
and the practical has a precedence for
stoics over the purely theoretical
the reason why we want to get all this
theoretical stuff right is so that we
can change our life
towards the better
and fulfill our duties and have our
faculty of choice in accordance with
nature and we can add all these other
things that stoicism is fundamentally
about
now this like i said you know this this
is something that academic philosophers
do quite often simply because somebody
can teach about stoicism doesn't mean
that they actually
follow it or or do you know anything
that's supposed to be like it although
presumably they would probably you know
not be as good in explaining it in
certain respects
there's a lot of academic philosophers
who never bother with the practical they
spend all of their time dealing with the
theoretical what we would call the
logical and epistemological
and they never end up getting around to
making sense out of the murky business
of their life and there's kind of a
disconnect there
there's a lot of ordinary people who do
this as well and this is something that
i think can be quite dangerous for
people who are engaging in
self-education
via the internet
which is a laudable thing i'm not
knocking it in any way but there can
often be too great an emphasis on you
know well have you met some these these
standards of proof you know what what
really counts as proof what if people
disagree about this or all these
epistemological and logical issues that
are real issues
but sometimes end up distracting from
actually putting things into practice
another thing that's important to keep
in mind is that from the stoic
perspective we're not totally rational
and you know even when we make progress
what we're doing is we're taking the
rational faculty and using it to improve
itself so it's more rational but it's
not like we have a perfectly fully
functioning rationality that can just
you know get the stuff right at the
third part and then it cascades down to
the you know the first part which which
is where action happens
acting choosing experiencing
reflecting on that
ends up informing the other parts as
well i mean how did the stoics end up
working out these other parts it wasn't
just by retiring off to the proverbial
armchair and then musing about them it
was through looking at their lives and
what would be necessary in order to make
some progress and then realizing well we
do need logic over here in order to make
some progress
now the other thing that i wanted to
talk about
in this is uh
he talks about this example of lying he
says we lie indeed but we're ready with
the arguments which prove that one ought
not to lie that is we recognize that
lying is is wrong and we even have great
arguments for it and we can trace them
back but there's a disconnect like i
said we we end up still lying we end up
still engaging in this practice of
falsehood
why is this one the example that
epictetus chooses
there there are so many other things
that we shouldn't do
that we can come up with ethical
prohibitions against that we could come
up with demonstrations or proofs or
arguments for why we ought not to do
that
why lying
that's worth considering
lying
is particularly detrimental from a stoic
perspective because every time that you
lie
there's some sort of contradiction
happening some sort of conflict
you don't just lie for the sake of
introducing a lie
into the world
although you know i suppose that is a
theoretical possibility
people lie when they're trying to cover
something up either in relation to other
people and what they think
or in relation to themselves
and
if we recognize for example that we
shouldn't lie to ourselves about the
progress that we're making but we do lie
to ourselves
we're going to have some difficulties
arise
you know in other places epictetus talks
for example about the fact that there's
some things that people will willingly
admit to doing wrong and then there's
other things that are sort of closer to
their heart and more embarrassing that
they don't want anyone to know about and
sometimes not even themselves
but unless you're actually willing to be
honest
you can't fix the things that are wrong
you can't work on the parts of yourself
that are damaged that are atrophied that
are in a bad state
so lying is a particularly good
example for him to use in this
our emphasis like he's saying here
especially if we're trying to improve
our lives has to be on this first part
of philosophy and the other parts have
to find their their necessity their
reason for being in that first part in
the use of its principles
upon every occasion we ought to have the
following thoughts at our command
lead thou me on o zeus and destiny to
that goal long ago to me a sign all
follow and not falter if my will prove
weak and craven still all follow on
who so has rightly with necessity
complied we count him wise and skilled
in things divine
well o credo if so it is pleasing to the
gods so let it be
anitus and meletus can kill me but they
cannot hurt me
epictetus's and caridian ends in a
particularly apt way with some thoughts
that he says that we ought to have at
our command that we ought to have
available to us that we can bring out
when they're helpful and i would suggest
that
these aren't the only ones these are
ones that epictetus recommends but
they're a bit distanced from us in in
time and culture so they might not be
perfectly applicable for us but
epictetus is works themselves and the
works of other stoics are chock-full of
plenty of other dogmata that is you know
these these thoughts that we can have
handy when we're dealing with
difficulties when we want to keep
ourselves on track now
this is not how epictetus ends the end
coridian this is how the person who
arranged all of these his disciple arius
arranged them but it is sort of a
definitive statement by epictetus he's
endorsing these and notice where these
are are coming from uh the first one is
from clayanthis this great stoic figure
the second skull arc
another is by a play by euripides it's
kind of a nice line that illustrates
stoic principles and then he's taking
things from from plato's works which are
about socrates and are showing us
socrates in his his character
so the first one he says uh that we
ought to think about runs like this lead
me on o zeus and destiny to that goal
long ago to me assigned
i'll follow and not falter if my will
prove weak and craven still i'll follow
on
that's a beautiful sentiment and i i do
want to mention that you know reading
through it in the greek
the translation is a little bit loose at
points
particularly the the last two verses
right so i'm going to follow and then he
says um
indigen methelo even if i don't want to
even if i don't choose to right this is
recognizing that we can sometimes have
what we might almost call a a split
faculty of choice a bifurcated will if
you like that we're not always 100
percent committed so then he says
cacos que nominos becoming bad right i
i'm i'm becoming uh
you know what i shouldn't be
um
still
uden
hebso mai
still
i won't any less
follow so
once we've decided that we're going to
put these principles into practice even
if we find ourselves lagging behind even
if we find ourselves you know falling
down on the job even if we find
ourselves in moral failure we can still
continue to follow we have to pick
ourselves up of course and then continue
on
and doing that will eventually produce a
will
that won't fall away
so that's the the first one the second
one from euripides who so has rightly
with necessity complying complied we
count him wise and skilled in things
divine wise you know so false the person
who really is the wise person and
skilled in things divine
knowledgeable
about
whatever is is is most transcendent if
divine bothers you because of the
theological
interpretation of it then think about
whatever matters most that person is
skilled within
and
the third the third one and the fourth
one are both from things that socrates
is saying so
the background of the credo one
is um credo
was a friend of socrates
and
when socrates has been condemned to
death
uh credo manages to bribe the guards
credo's rich right and he comes up with
arguments for socrates you need to leave
and here's why and socrates says well
let's consider those those arguments not
quite sure if i should leave
socrates viewed his engaging in
philosophy
as a divine mission as as something that
was assigned to him as his role as what
he was meant to do
by the gods or by the god specifically
apollo because there's a whole story
about the oracle
and so he he ends up saying
well oh credo
if so it is pleasing to the gods so let
it be if if something really is pleasing
to the gods then that's what we're going
to do
how do you figure out what is pleasing
to the gods for socrates
it's not by going to the oracle so much
although his friend does that kind of
joking around and then gets this whole
ball rolling
it's rather that the gods are rational
and the gods
want us to do what reason rightly
governed reason rightly developed reason
bids us to do
so if socrates comes up with arguments
for why he should stay and face
execution
then he takes that as being what the
gods want him to do for the stoics it's
very important to follow reason
where it leads
the last one
is from his trial
the apology apology means defense speech
and socrates has been brought to trial
by by these two guys uh anatis and
melitus
uh melitus talks during an anatus is in
another dialogue amino
and they are
charging him with
various crimes corruption of the young
impiety these were capital crimes
so they are threatening him by use of
the law court with the death penalty
and notice what socrates says
anatis and melitus can kill me
but they cannot hurt me
they cannot harm me they cannot damage
me
why why should we remind ourselves of
that because when we face situations
where people
are doing things that we feel are
hurtful we should ask ourselves are they
hurting our reputation but not myself
are they hurting my body but not myself
are they hurting my possessions but not
myself and here somebody might say wait
they're hurting my feelings or they're
offending against the rationality that i
know
well they can't really
according to the stoics hurt your
feelings unless you are already desiring
them to see you in a certain way or
averse to them seeing you in a certain
way or talking to you in a certain way
if what they do doesn't really matter to
you as as good or bad because it's up to
them it's not up to us
they can't hurt you
all they can do is take away their
affection take away the honor that
you're being given take away your
possessions take away perhaps even your
bodily existence
but they cannot hurt you they cannot
coerce the core that is your faculty of
choice your rational faculty your ruling
faculty that is free that is unhindered
if you choose it to be so and so that is
a very fitting place to end this entire
commentary on this wonderful work by
epictetus
end caridian
[Music]
you